welcome to this video our penguin ok
let's see ya reti opening what is he
doing d4c 60-64 ok game to play quick
before yet the sharpest move let's see
what is doing against it quite funny
type of link opening blacks best move
now probably is f 6m which however not
so many people are playing yeah this one
after that I can't play a reverse
blumenfeld so quite funny with e3 this
gives white some very nice compensation
actually let's just play normal moose
get the center and try to try to drum up
a quick attack okay maybe just
cancelling ha so maybe this one what he
did here is neglecting the the
development of the queenside a little
bit 95 maybe maybe I can play with the
95 idea here
okay so taking with the rook I guess aha
interesting so if I check here
hmm interesting yeah black is of course
to fairly solid maybe I should just
develop a little bit there is nothing
dramatic to be done thought maybe if a
chick now here maybe he can just take
with the night actually that's not so
bad oh yeah oh wow this wasn't a good
opening what I played yet I mean the
opening itself is ok but what I played
right after Bishop hang snow yeah that's
really not this this whole thing is not
really fitting together very well I have
a nice center but it's not oh it's not
trading Queens interestingly enough I
would have expected that ok maybe I can
untangle a little bit here but check now
I actually have an idea look at this how
we'll see how is he preventing this on
h7 now g6 is not on
Jeff juki business thank you you know
that the capture but I can also just
move the Queen now i believe and pet put
him in a pin here like this Queen e7 I o
Queen d4 and I'm covering the rock yeah
it was funny from a good position it
went downhill in like two or three moves
for black maybe no yeah I have bishop a
three-year this is this is important um
but take it let me think about it for a
moment check HERE rope the aid i have
bishop and i know i have could create
naquin d successes is easier group t8
Bishop e3 was a little bit tougher black
resigns yeah that was weird I mean
around here black is just okay I think
let's let's have a look here I think
this was probably not a great idea let's
I can just take out here and I think
he's more or less a healthy porn up
let's say he and here yeah I really
played didn't play this very well yeah
kesling is just not working he has to do
something like that and yeah this is not
so clear I mean it's a nice center and I
don't have any bad pieces so maybe it is
something like close to compensation
don't know but this is what he needs to
do here yeah yeah I'm really just
winning
yeah Queen takes and if he goes rook
here i have bishop a 30 I mean I could
also just move the Queen because
Shadrach f1 yeah so he just blundered
this away from a good position okay
thanks for watching